what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot of people have been very eager
to find out about the future of the
Scarlet Witch to know what road is she
going to go down in the MCU and as it
turns out the road that she might go
down is the witch's Road and we'll dive
into this story that's from the comics
and what it could be in the MCU and will
also announce the giveaway winner at the
end of this video a lot has happened
with Wanda story in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and just like they did in the
comics they've ret conned her backstory
in the MCU to make it to where she's not
a mutant but she was actually born a
witch who had her powers Amplified by an
experiment now in the comics this was
the high evolutionary who actually
experimented on Wanda now we were just
introduced to the high evolutionary and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 and
clearly he is not the one who
experimented on Wanda in the MCU she got
her powers or her experimentation was
from an infinity stone and Hydra however
of course as we have gone on throughout
the years we find out that she is indeed
the Scarlet Witch and there have been
rumors that a Scarlet Witch solo project
a movie or a Disney Plus show it's
unconfirmed at this time is going to
actually begin production this year and
on that note San Diego Comic-Con is
about a month away a little over a month
and we are expecting some pretty big
announcements for Marvel Studios
including hopefully fingers crossed the
full reveal of phase six of the MCU and
if the rumors are true in a Solo Scarlet
Witch Project is about to start
production in 2023 or even
pre-production then maybe the Scarlet
Witch solo story is going to be on that
Phase 6 slate and if Wanda is going to
play a pretty big role in secret Wars
which he probably is since it involves
the Multiverse it would make sense for
her movie or project to come out before
Secret Wars also Doctor Strange 3 since
they were dealing with incursions in the
Multiverse in that movie as well and of
course the story of Wanda the Scarlet
Witch but if what these insiders are
reporting is true for what the story is
going to be based off of or this
upcoming solo project Wanda is no longer
going to be a villain but she actually
could be trying to make amends which
totally makes sense Wanda was never
really a bad person at heart she was
good however she did Kill A lot of
people in Multiverse Madness but it
looks like the villain Ark isn't going
to continue and it also looks like the
story in Agatha coven of chaos is going
to play a pretty big role in what
happens with the Scarlet Witch as well
specifically in regards to her two
children Billy and Tommy and from what
we've heard in Agatha coven of chaos
Billy is going to be in the show and
he's going to be looking for his brother
Tommy and he's going to have a guide
helping him and according to Alex P from
the cosmic circus that guide is actually
going to be Agatha herself now in the
comics a lot happens with Agatha
Harkness But ultimately especially for
the witch's Road storyline Agatha ends
up becoming Wanda's Mentor you see in
the comics Agatha isn't exactly bad she
even looks after Franklin Richards the
son of Reed Richards and Sue storm of
the Fantastic Four she's good so I'm
expecting that to happen in the MCU as
well especially if she is helping
Wanda's son Billy find her other son
Tommy which would then in turn probably
lead to Wanda finding the both of them
which could lead to Agatha being Wanda's
Mentor in the MCU because our new report
today comes from two insiders with great
track records can we get some toast and
Alex P from the cosmic circus both
stating that they have heard that Marvel
Studios is going to do the witch's Road
story for the Scarlet Witch in the MCU
now this is a very interesting story
from the comics which actually involves
another Scarlet Witch and another
powerful Sorcerer And what's curious
about this and I'm not sure if they'll
adapt this into the MCU but as I
mentioned Agatha in this story is the
mentor for Wanda however she's dead the
mentor is the ghost about the hardness
and the kicker is Wanda actually killed
her in the comics after Wanda loses her
children much like she does in the MCU
Agatha wipes her memory so she doesn't
have to deal with the pain however once
the Scarlet Witch finds out she kills
Agatha now Agatha was her Mentor at the
time and basically continues to be her
Mentor as a ghost and eventually is
resurrected again she comes back to life
not sure if we'll see that in the MCU
but it is still a pretty cool story
especially if you consider the fact that
she erases the memory of her children
because the last time that we saw Wanda
she was in search of her children but
now we know that her children are going
to be in Agatha coven of chaos and
Agatha is going to be helping her
children so it looks like Agatha and the
Scarlet which are actually going to be
friends and allies and perhaps Agatha
does Mentor Wanda in the MCU now as far
as the witch's road is concerned the
witch's road is actually another
dimension that only extremely powerful
Sorcerers can access and when Wanda goes
inside the witch's Road in the comics
she runs into her mother her real mother
Natalia maximoff who is accessing the
realm at the same time from a different
point in time Wanda and Agatha come
across her and ask who she is and she
says she is known by many names but she
is the Scarlet Witch you see Wanda's
True Mother in the comics was the
Scarlet Witch before she was then Agatha
is basically like hey that's your mother
but be careful because if it's your
mother from a previous time telling her
that you're her daughter telling her the
future could change the future so her
mother Natalia wonders who she is and
Wanda simply says well my last name is
maximoff too so perhaps we're distant
relatives at that point in time Natalia
sent us a present uses a spell to show a
very large hiding beast and does another
spell to Vanquish it in which she then
goes I now realize who you are I haven't
met or been with a man yet in my
timeline but you are my duh and she
immediately leaves around before she
finishes the word daughter so Wanda
meets her real mother in The Witch's
road which would be something that would
be very cool to see in the MCU but she
also comes across another powerful
sorcerer who is indeed a villain and
that is Declan Dane the emerald warlock
now Declan had basically been putting
curses on lands and magic and every time
Wanda used her magic she died a little
bit it took a year off of her life so
essentially when she goes to fight him
in the witch's Road each time she uses
her magic he absorbs her power and she
continues to die however while he's
doing his big bad villain speech in
Wanda's aging she all of a sudden comes
out and says yeah I'm gonna die of old
age one day but not today then her
appearance goes back to her normal
younger self in which he then asks how
did you do this and she explains while
you were doing your big bad speech she
moved them to the world of cerinos the
realm of the mother goddess this is a
place where female witches get extreme
power from the mother goddess and Men
even Immortal men like the World warlock
have no power so she defeats him and
then claims that from there on out they
will be Arch enemies and this is what we
could see happen in the MCU in Agatha
coven of chaos of course we're going to
learn more about witches and Witchcraft
and dark magic in the MCU and Wanda's
kids are going to be there plus Wanda's
Mentor in the comics it's all about her
Agatha and from what we've heard she's
not exactly going to be a villain in her
own series she's not exactly going to be
a hero but not a villain which could
lead her to go on to eventually
reconcile with Wanda and offer to teach
her what she knows Agatha has been
around for hundreds maybe thousands of
years in the MCU and she definitely
could teach Wanda a lot and if Agatha
helps her find her kids I'm sure she'd
be willing to listen and be grateful and
it sounds like by the end of Agatha
coven of chaos Agatha is indeed going to
be caring emotionally that is for
Wanda's kids so a big Redemption Arc for
the Scarlet Witch could be coming in the
witch's Road story she is doing magical
tasks and helping defeat villains as a
way to repay for what she's done in the
past that could definitely be what we
see in the MCU Wanda feeling bad for
everything that she did in Multiverse of
Madness and now trying to make up for it
either way this sounds like it could be
an incredibly great story Wanda possibly
running into her birth mother in The
Witch's Road plane and then running into
the emerald warlock I'm definitely here
for the story but hey let us know what
you think about this in the comments
down below and congratulations to
YouTube user big will 8296 you are the
winner of our May giveaway be sure to
email me so you can claim your prize and
for the rest of you we are starting a
June giveaway we give away a PS5 an Xbox
series X Marvel Legends items or some DC
items each month the winner gets to pick
one item and at the end of the month we
pick a winner so still a ton of more
chances to win the giveaway prize all
you gotta do to enter a subscribe and
leave a comment Down Below on our videos
also don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
me